[music]
perfect 1 album
andrey sokolov five was an exhibition
tokyo game show is always a so-called
unit of his pants rhymes andrey sokolov
led the
hellsing course
testament in da sind even volkhin with
children on the stone states and backup
celeste
here you are advice camp shame 305  Sombre is worth
surprising and files and set of tools
and he could hold for him in bright and
fundamental freedoms
only Soviet, of course,
sugars,
his ideas that the progress of the world,
security and human rights is
connected, and suddenly
it is very, very important to find other things that are inextricably linked and
find her you and open file and high
tide Isakov vpo and spo films then he
this is your
faculty, the flange of the new one, these
invites yandex
individual given on the tape, was found in the
advance, was arrested in the film itself, the new
lonely world,
and when  and the person with whom we
started together, yes, the work of the memorial,
his award, you come to the memorial, this is
very much learned from this, what is important, because
such an award, like the example of
Andrey Demich Sakharova, it clearly
shows the inseparability of human rights
throughout the world of fantasies, the chance of fatality
stakes is dedicated to topics  forgot parts of the
pump
[applause] an
indicator for the rest of the world that everything
can be resolved peacefully and calmly with
dignity the principle of this wall
is a way to save a negative bonus for this,
but free belts are a premium
knife to us popov's energy but for the sake of
prefetch the head is wet for which the
communist parties
0  antonia fish
you he
[music]
[applause]